hey there I'm Alicia Malone with
Fandango movie clips and these are some
of the films are most excited to see at
the 2015 South by Southwest festival in
Austin Texas
beginning with the opening night film
brand a second coming now I am so
fascinated by Russell Brand he's a
comedian slash actor slash activist who
we all know from his very public image
his career his relationships his battle
with addictions now he's had a change of
heart and he's grappling with the very
idea of Fame and also about society as a
whole
this documentary promises to reveal that
other side to him another film which
looks really intriguing is ex machina
this is the directorial debut from Alex
Garland he is a genius writer who wrote
one of my favorite books called the
beach ex machina looks like a very
stylish sci-fi thriller it stars
domhnall gleeson as a computer
programmer who's hired by an eccentric
CEO played by Oscar Isaac to test out
his new Android called Ava but as often
happens in these kind of movies when a
eyes develop feelings things don't go to
plan and that is so much fun to watch on
film
what will happen to me if I fail your
test the Brian Wilson biopic love and
mercy is also having its debut at the
South by Southwest festival this is an
unconventional look at the lead singer
from the Beach Boys starring Paul Dano
as the younger Brian Wilson and John
Cusack as the older Brian Wilson now I
wouldn't think to put these two actors
as the same person but I'm really
looking forward to seeing Paul Dano in
more of a lead role in my opinion he's
one of the best young actors around
today also interested to find out more
about the Beach Boys and Brian Wilson
because really I know nothing I'm also
excited for a brave heart the Lizzy
Velasco story because documentaries are
my jam years ago when Lizzy found a
video online calling her the world's
ugliest woman she decided to stand up
and try to make a change for
cyberbullying she did this fantastic
talk at the TED women conference back in
2013 which went viral and since then
she's been plunged into the spotlight
and she's campaigning for the first-ever
federal bill against bullying I'm so
inspired by this premise I can't wait to
see it on the big screen and finally
there's manglehorn because who can say
no to an hour Pacino movie who are who
in this he plays a locksmith who is
battling with his memories of a past
crime which cost him the love of his
life
I adore Al Pacino I think he still has
some fantastic performances in him and
even though this film premiered at the
Venice Film Festival and didn't get very
good reviews I'm really willing to give
this a go because I also loved the
director David Gordon Green he has been
behind some really interesting films
from the crazy pineapple express to the
really interesting in deep jokes so I
will be checking this one out so those
are just a few of the films I'm looking
forward to it this year's South by
Southwest festival but there is so much
going on Fandango movie clips will be
covering the South by Southwest festival
all week long so make sure you subscribe
and stay tuned for fare Nagar movie
clips I'm Alisha Malone